okay let's go to the dark side of crypto
I love us three three three things so
one is let's talk about call air quotes
professional investors right so funds
and venture capital etcetera buying
tokens at huge discounts and not
disclosing positions and then dumping on
retail
what the [ __ ] coin waterfalls so so
explain kind of your perspective as to
what's been going on really I think you
know some of it hopefully is dissipating
a little bit but maybe not as fast as we
want it to but but explain kind of how
that happens and then where you think
things need to change
sure so I'll quickly describe the [ __ ]
coin waterfall it's it's a terrible way
of saying something but I'm okay so the
[ __ ] coin waterfall is this you get a
bunch of people together and they're
like we want to do this crypto project
we're gonna build a decentralized
computing protocol right great and so
they go to a small group of investors
typically insiders known people in the
crypto space they're like hey we're
doing a pre seed round we're doing like
a pre pre sale we're gonna give you
tokens at this price and everyone writes
their checks and they raise a couple
million bucks great they don't get to go
mark it and hire more people and then
they get to a point where they put out a
white paper or something more
articulated to the market and they go to
a bigger group of investors and
institutions they're like hey who are
less who are less on the inside before I
left on the inside right and they're
like hey we're doing a pre-sale look at
the people in this pre presale they're
awesome but we're doing presale now and
we're gonna give you a price that is 10x
what they paid okay great so they pay
10x more and then they're like okay
we're gonna do presale bigger audience
less informed you get less information
less insight and they're like hey we're
we're gonna let you in and it's at 100x
what the pre pre sale people paid and
10x at the pre sale people pay so you
create this later'd structure all right
in this kind of resembles liquidation
preferences yep right in in a
traditional corporation and so you have
this structure and then you're like okay
we're gonna list the tokens on the
market and they have all these
announcements and they're going around
telling their pre pre sale masters like
hey here's our plan
here's we're gonna do here's what's
going on
and then the prepuce sale investors by
the way all collaborate together to say
okay we're gonna buy we're gonna sell
they can manipulate the price of these
assets and actually my research teams
been working on analyzing movement of
coins like the network topology of some
of these tokens through the process of
listing and how that sort of evolves
over time there's some shady [ __ ] people
do and what ends up happening is people
start dumping their coins on the market
retail starts buying it there's this
narrative that gets created like this is
an amazing coin look at how innovative
it is look who backed it look go back to
it right look at the founders this is
amazing this is so phenomenal they do a
bunch of marketing they throw a bunch of
events they do maybe a couple of press
releases or partnerships or
announcements where they're paying
people for partnership and then retail
buys up these tokens everyone's eggs in
their position and it just starts
dumping and the thing is the reason the
[ __ ] coin waterfall has worked
historically is because investors knew
there was always a buyer of last resort
who was not them I think in this market
right now because retail has lost their
appetite
there is no buyer of last resort it's
institutions selling bags to one another
and so I think ultimately this just
becomes a game of who gets the most
information the fastest and who can dump
the fastest absolutely well in it now
leads us to a problem of how much
capital inflow is actually going on
versus are we just recycling funds right
and I think the circularity of capital
is really problematic and you see this
like when a venture funds invest in a in
a crypto protocol they do niceö they
raise money from other VCS then and take
that money and give it to another VC to
invest in more startups who then create
tokens that the VC buys that then the
protocols it's like the circularity is
incredible and I think part of it is
there is no utility for these tokens
there's speculative assets for ideas
that are poorly implemented in some
cases um and look it's not a criticism I
sympathize with people of really big
visions and are trying to build them but
I think the circularity of capital
problem if everyone's motivated by
financial return what ends up happening
is you have people who have a short time
frame they've short attention span and
the minute that it's no longer worth
spending a minute of time on a project
because you're not going to get any
juice out of it
that's your incentive as an investor to
spend time on it